next we're sharing some of our favorite
diy ideas and i'm really excited about
this hopefully we're going to be doing
it a lot this week
call me pinterest pinterest pop
okay i love pinterest i actually got on
it like
right away when social media started but
i didn't have an account like i was like
flower lady22
i might even still have it but now we're
in the game i've got a real account and
we're filling it up like crazy
but we are about to talk to someone who
is the queen
of pinterest herself she is the most
popular pinner
on the site with 14 million
followers you don't even understand what
that means
on pinterest that is like catastrophic
or out of the sphere and her love of
design started with a job as a graphic
designer and now she runs this hugely
successful lifestyle brand called oh joy
so
please welcome joy cho
hi joy oh my gosh
i just want to get right in and ask you
how do you do it i bet
everybody watching who is obsessed with
pinterest like we are
how do you run a successful account do
you have any tips like
what have you learned along the way it's
so exciting to get into the mind of
someone who has
really done it you know i started
pinterest 10 years ago and
for me it's all about following your gut
i'm just such a visual person
i love things that make people happy and
so when i see something
i pin it when i see something that's
inspiring to me i know it's going to be
inspiring
to other people as well that's smart so
don't like over curate
like be true to yourself and don't think
about what someone else would do think
about what you would do
i'm always just about don't look at
other people do what feels good in your
heart
and put those in different categories
save them for ideas
share what you want and just trust your
gut
huh i love that advice uh peter grumbine
who's like one of our heads at digital
with the show cause i was like i'll just
put my instagram like account into the
show like
you know i'm just kind of naive and he's
like no no that's not how this works you
stay you
be you in your world you're that you're
someone different in this show i mean
you're you
but it's a different platform and he
always says trust your gut
and we've been through 2020 together so
social media in 2020 has been very
difficult
and very nuanced to navigate and i'm
glad i've had someone who's said that
very advice to me so
i think people will really find a lot of
value in that joy thank you for sharing
that
okay so what are we gonna do today i'm
so excited to learn a craft from you
joy so i'm all about bringing joy into
your everyday in simple ways in ways
that don't make you feel like you have
to go get a million things from places
that you don't know so
we're going to decorate vases
these are just simple drinking glasses
that i have turned into decorated vases
using clear paper and i don't know if
you remember this paper
but back when we were in school the
teacher used to put this up on a
projector and write on it it's called
projector paper
it's just clear paper i've got the milky
kind will that still work
um it'll work fine but i'm sorry
joy i've let you down already no big
deal we're all fine but the whole point
is that you can decorate a vase
a jar look this is just a jar that came
with jam
and you can turn it into this wonderful
new thing and it's not
permanent you can change it on a whim
you can change it depending on
what you're celebrating and all you're
going to need
is paint some acrylic paint uh-huh
acrylic paint good to know because i'd
be like out there with watercolor and
oil good
good okay i've got oh this is just so
beautiful thank you for this trace set
up guys i appreciate it
um and you're paint on the paper like
this
oh i've already oh joy gosh darn it
i've already messed it up can i do it on
the glass or you know what
here i've got an extra piece aren't i a
good student
i'm just gonna paint right on here i'm
gonna hold this up so you can see mine
you can do something abstract you could
do stripes you could do squiggles
whatever you know what also i'm i have a
question which is like sometimes i will
receive flowers and the shape of the
vase
is very nice um because you know the
neck of a vase sometimes you want them
to splay out sometimes you want them
to stand up so the shape of the vase is
integral to the way you want to arrange
flowers but sometimes i don't love the
vase itself can i do this on larger
vases as well
absolutely the only key thing is it
needs to be a cylinder with straight
sides
because you're basically cutting a flat
piece and you're going to wrap it around
and that will only work if it's a
cylinder ah capiche
you could obviously paint right on glass
the only thing the thing about this it's
not
that it's not permanent and if you're
doing an actual drinking glass you want
to use again later you're not ruining
that glass
okay i'm i don't know why i'm feeling
polka dots it's what's coming to me
polka dots are pretty timeless and i'm
going with the colors
um that you directed to use are i have
to say
of course i poured through your
pinterest and i was
just overwhelmed with how incredible
the way your use of color is and
when we are doing our design in the
brands that we do
my partners anna um and francesca
anna will literally say to me color
changes everything it's one of the best
rules she's taught me and it really does
your use of colors joy is
really incredibly inspiring um
okay so all right i've made this
i don't know why this was my inspiration
oh see
you're i like yours better okay that's
fine
and then all you're gonna do you would
have already pre-measured this to wrap
around whatever size you need you're
gonna wrap it around
and then get a piece of other
double-sided or regular tape
and secure it in the back
how do you like me joy i might like i
just ridiculous
there we go all right look
[Applause]
mean you get your flowers and fill them
up
i love it joy thank you i would really
love to
collab with you again i'll try to get my
stuff better you know together next time
see i can't even say it
but um i would love to continue to know
you and do a collab with you anything
i'd love to learn from you
i have a lot of admiration for you and
i'm really really honored you came on
the show today thank you
thank you for having me thank you joy
okay oh joy.com
and obviously joychow on pinterest the
most famous pinterester someone i've
learned a lot from already
you